c'est une revue d'effectif au coeur
d'une section sportive de valognes
composé uniquement de filles
voilà trois ans maintenant que les
lycéennes d'henri corps n'a pas trois
heures de leur temps scolaire sur les
gazons du stade du club local
et donc là on est sur les onze 11 jours
l'unique sélection de foot féminin des
lycées du département insu pu voir le
jour en 2017 grâce à l'académie de
district ainsi que la collectivité
locale on commence quand même à voir
quelque chose qui ressemble à une équipe
là maintenant progressivement malgré ces
progrès sinon on va y aller et jeune
fille qui faisait du football féminin
sur le département de la manche et qui
souvent étaient scolarisés à brécey au
collège était contrainte d'aller à caen
à jean rostand n'y avait pas de
structure dans la manche et la création
de ces structures là permet aussi de
raccrocher beaucoup de jeunes filles qui
se découragent est assez vite en allant
à caen pour diverses raisons a notamment
d'éloignement mais aussi d'intégration
dans un club où elle n'avait pas
forcément elle n'avait pas évolué ce ne
sont pas des sélections surprofits
scolaire c'est-à-dire qu'on ne s'en
n'est vraiment sûr du profil sportif
par contre effectivement on s'assure que
les élèves vont pouvoir suivre une
scolarité normale au lycée et avoir au
bout du compte le baccalauréat et
poursuivre leurs études supérieures
depuis la rentrée 2010 9 elles sont plus
d'une dizaine d'adolescentes à suivre
ainsi un cursus scolaire tout en
pratiquant leur sport de prédilection
répartis dans les classes de la seconde
à la terminale tout pour la plupart sont
originaires du département de la manche
au départ c'était ma passion le foot on
que je vais continuer mes études tout en
faisant ma passion échoué que c'était
une bonne idée pour après l'avenir aussi
parce que vu que je suis très sportive à
travailler ça m'aurait fait un petit
aussi bon qu'au lycée je pouvais faire
deux choses en main
travailler dans des périodes que ça vend
des actifs turner j'ai un coup de temps
si je n'ai pas ici mais il y avait plein
entraînement de foot pour moi parce que
c'était le soir et en fine c'est trop
tard oriali loin de leurs familles ces
filles vivent pour la majorité d'entre
elles en internat au quotidien il s'agit
donc de jongler entre les cours et le
foot
un emploi du temps pour le moins rythmée
à l'heure des séances de foot ici à puis
remises et de redmond sur un côté je
vais lui donner et à rentrer avec le
ballon là bas j'avais envie d'avoir plus
entraînements forcément
et puis au collège j'ai déjà été en
internat et du coup la vie d'antan c'est
c'est bien ça change un petit peu de la
famille donc voilà allez allez olla
assez dans la surface ça sera une touche
les jeunes filles sont passionnés et
chercha progresse à elles sont
exigeantes exigeante envers elle même en
disant tendent vers les autres
l'objectif est de poursuivre leur
formation
et effectivement le week-end et jeunes
filles restent dans leur club et
profitent justement de toute cette
formation la sueur sur les semaines et
les mois pour justement progresser
continuer en tout l'état et faire
profiter les clubs les clubs locaux
le district de football de la manche
espère retenir ses joueuses et voir
ainsi ses efforts récompensés en
comptant ce département plus de 1500
licenciés
ouais